The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aihi
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
Asalam allayikum.
How are you guys doing? Richard Dawkins
is a new atheist who is also an
evolutionary biologist has written many
um bestsellers against religion probably
most notably the god delusion which he
wrote in 2008
uh at a time actually where new atheism
was I would say on the ascendancy. Now
it's actually on a very steep decline.
And he started to speak about uh
religion and has responded to me as
you'll see in these clips because maybe
he realizes that new atheism is dying
and he needs to rescue it from uh
complete or resuscitate it from complete
death. So he tries to respond. Let's
take a look at the first clip and
respond to that clip in kind. The
universe is very complex. that if you
look at the properties of the universe
as documented by theistic and atheistic
cosmologists, they refer to a fine
tuning of the universe. I talked about
Martin Ree who wrote a book just six
numbers. He details six numbers. All of
these numbers he says describe the
reality of the universe. He said had one
of these numbers been different, the
universe would not be able to facilitate
human life and there would not be a fine
tuning of the universe or the universe
could not exist in the complex way it
does. If we look around and see the
intelligent design, it must really
follow that we say that there must be an
intelligent designer. Do you see what I
mean? Martin Ree did indeed write a book
called just six numbers and he did
indeed say that if any one of those
numbers the fundamental constants of
physics had been a little bit different,
you wouldn't have got the universe as we
know it and you wouldn't have got life.
And that's a very respectable argument
which physicists often put. Um there are
various answers to it. uh one is that um
if the universe had been different
because of this then maybe a different
kind of life would have evolved. But a
much more much more powerful argument is
the one that Martin Ree himself actually
prefers and which that speaker whoever
it was ignored which is to say that
there is a multiverse. There are other
good reasons to expect a multiverse.
There are other good reasons which
physicists have. It follows from other
physical theories that there will be not
just one universe with one set of
physical constants but millions of
universes with different values of the
physical constants and most of those
universes will not be conducive to life
will not be conducive to producing uh
galaxies to producing planets to
producing chemistry to producing life.
uh but a minority maybe only a very
small minority will be and of course we
have to be living in one of that
minority because here we are that's the
so-called anthropic principle and that's
the argument that Martin Ree himself
puts forward in that very book which
that man selectively quoted okay so
that's very interesting because he
starts off with a kind of cordial tone a
very respectful tone and he he refers to
the argument that I put forward and this
is an argument maybe I made about seven
or eight years ago He he calls it
actually a respectable argument and he's
a familiar with the work of Martin Ree
who wrote the book just six numbers.
Now, of course, I've developed this
argument quite considerably throughout
my PhD and my thesis, which hopefully
will be done um maybe in the next year
or so and then I can publish it and
people can read it uh on the contingency
argument for God's existence. And I do
have specialized chapters and
specialized talking points about the
finetuning. But it should be noted that
this is not a point of controversy
between us the theists and you guys the
new atheists or whatever is you refer to
yourself as because Richard Dawkins
himself mentions in the god delusion
which is a book that was written in 2008
that there is a life permitting range
which he refers to actually as a
goldilock zone that the proportions of
the universe are significantly
proportioned in a manner that had they
been different that life would not exist
in the universe. That is something he
admits to quite freely in the God
delusion. In fact, Christopher Hitchens,
another person of the um of the new
atheist movement. He was there was a
video of him speaking about this
particular argument and he considers it
as well or at least he implies it's a
very respectable argument. But then
Richard Dawkins comes and says, well,
what about the multiverse? What about if
there's millions of universes, etc.,
etc. And then he refers to what is
referred to or he refers to as the weak
anthropic principle that the universe
had the universe not been the way it is
we wouldn't have observed it as such and
therefore it's kind of he is downplaying
the significance of the fact that the
universe has certain proportions which
allow life to exist in it and this is
the fine-tuning argument the response to
this has already been he's already heard
the response to this from people like
John Leslie who have repudiated the
weakanthropic principle which is now
rubbished in all of philosophy in a
manner that I'm surprised he's actually
mentioning it again after how heavily he
was repudiated by John Lennox and
others. John Leslie mentions that the
similitude of saying that the universe
is the way it is because we observed it
as such is the same as had somebody been
uh for let's say for example you got
Richard Dawkins and he's being shot by
50 marksmen okay so you got Richard
Dawkins on the mall and then you got
expert marksmen pointing the gun at
Richard Dawkins and shooting and trying
to aim at his head trying to shoot him
and kill him yeah you got 50 marksmen
that trying to kill him and destroy
And these are expert marksmen who are
not too far away from him, you know,
they all miss.
And then Richard Dawkins, he looks
around and sees all the bullets and he
says, "Well, I'm so lucky because had
that not been the case, I would not be
here. Had that not been the case, I had
not been here." So John Leslie is saying
the similitude of saying that the
universe had it not been the case it we
wouldn't be able to observe it is the
same as the person who was subject to
that barrage of fire shots fired by the
marksmen would be the same as that
particular analogy.
Now in a nutshell what you can say is
it's a tortological talking point. You
cannot explain a thing by a thing and
explain that to expect that to be an
explanation. In fact, that contravenes
the principle of sufficient reason. A
principle that was promulgated of course
by lieness but by others even atheists
like Arthur Schopenhau who I don't want
to go into much detail here but he
actually wrote his PhD thesis on the
four uh four points of the principle of
sufficient reason many people throughout
the time of Aristotle etc. The question
is why why is the universe proportioned
in such a manner?
Why is it proportioned in such a manner
that had it not been proportioned in
this manner that life would not exist?
What's the explanation for that? And you
citing the observable universe as an
explanation is not actually an
explanation. It's a tortological
talking point and you have to understand
that. Then he mentions the multiverse.
The multiverse does not answer this
question because say for example going
back to the marksman point if Richard
Dawkins after you know 50 people tried
to kill him with with guns and he's and
then he comes out and he says wow I'm so
lucky I have not been killed by the 50
expert marksmen who are trying to shoot
my head off but then he says well many
people who have been aimed at by
marksmen have been killed
this is the similitude because he's
basically saying you have many potential
universes which by the way there's no
scientific evidence for there's no
scientific evidence for any multiverse
by the way there's no tangible
observable evidence but for the sake of
argument
even if you do site whether a finite or
infinite number of multiverses to try
and repudiate the idea of a finetuning
or the fact that the universe is
proportioned in such a manner un
uniformly and regularly
in order to allow life to exist then
that would not be a sufficient
explanation because it's the the
similitude of that would be to say well
many people have been killed by a
marksman just because I have not been
killed by a a marksman or 50 marksmen
that tried to kill me it doesn't mean
anything or it's not significant
it is still significant that even if
everybody else who's been shot by
marksmen has been killed you not being
shot by marksmen who are trying to kill
you is significant and our question is
what's the best explanation for that.
You said it's a respectable it's a
respectable argument and you so you
understand that but you don't have a
sufficient response. Your responses have
been repudiated heavily in the
philosophy of religion in in in even
physics physicists have realized that
this is a nonsense argument and that's
why barely anyone uses the weak
anthropic principle except for you. So
that's my first response to your first
query and let's move to the second one.
What happened before? Say you go for the
big bang argument. Physicists are
debating this. I'm not a physicist, but
they're debating it. My point is that
they don't know and I don't know and you
don't know. And it doesn't help to
postulate a god that did it. How do you
know that he doesn't know if you don't
know? I mean, this doesn't make sense to
me. And he does this all the time. If
you're an ignorant person, then how do
you know that someone else's ignorance
is identical to your ignorance if you're
ignorant? Having your epistemological
cake and eating it as well at the same
time? How can you have both? If you're
ignorant, then don't be an arrogant
ignorant person. Because if you're an
agnostic, which of course you call
yourself an atheist. I mean, Richard
Dawkins calls himself an atheist, but in
reality, he's an agnostic. So, he's
saying, "I don't know, but you don't
know as well." But then if you don't
know, how do you know that he doesn't
know? If you don't know, it's arrogant
ignorance. Let's just call you what you
are, Richard Dawkins. You're an arrogant
man because you're postulating what
other people do or do not know, but also
you're an ignorant man because
agnosticism is basically ignorance.
That's all it is. I said sort of
standard rhetorical device, I don't
know, and you don't know and physicists
don't know. Well, um it's true that I
don't know and physicists don't know.
And if and if physicists don't know,
then Piers Morgan most certainly doesn't
know. And therefore, although it's it's
correct that I don't actually know
whether Pers Morgan knows anything, um
I'm pretty confident in saying that if
the physicists don't know the answer to
that question, he doesn't either.
So here, if you listen to what he says,
he goes, well, how do I know? And we're
talking about epistemology here. How do
I know that you know that you know all
that kind of thing? And he's basically
saying, well, that's of course it's
correct. I don't know what Piers Morgan
meant. He says it's correct. If it's
correct, I could just suffice with that
and say if I'm correct, then I can just
leave it there. It's correct that you
don't know if he's ignorant or not. If
if you if you're not sure if he's
ignorant or not, then that's it. It's
sufficient. You shouldn't arrogate that.
However, you then move on to say, well,
if physicists don't know it, then
Pierers Morgan won't know it. Who made
physicists the ultimate arbiter for all
ultimate questions? That's my question
to you.
Even if you read Steven Hawkins, which
I'm sure you have, brief history of
time, almost anyone who speaks about the
universe, especially like even Sean
Carroll, I've I've read something of
him, someone who also debated William
Lane Craig. I debated William Lane
Craig. Sean Carol debated him. You
didn't, by the way, Richard Dawkins,
because for whatever reason, you you
didn't want to debate a philosopher. And
I can understand why you wouldn't want
to engage with me either.
Of course, you're welcome to. We can
have a discussion. I'll be very cordial
with you, very respectful with you and
this and that. It can be on your
channel, his channel or a third party
channel, could be a debate, could be a
discussion, could be a podcast that's
always open to you Dr. Lawkins and it'll
be a very interesting discussion or you
can discuss with my friend Sab Ahmed who
is a specialist in evolutionary matters
when it comes to the philosophy of
biology etc and linking that to faith
and theology. So you have these options.
But the point I'm making to you is
physicists are not the ultimate arbiter
for the ultimate questions about what
happened before the big bang.
Because the question of what before the
big bang or what explained the big bang,
what caused the big bang or whatever it
may be that you want to formulate.
The question about that is a
philosophical question because it
requires inference.
If you say, well, let's for the sake of
argument, let's assume that you would
say it's a multiverse. for the sake of
argument, infinite or finite amount of
universes, then still you need to have
an explanation for your multiverse.
What's the best explanation for your
multiverse? And if you do have a
multiverse of an infinite or finite
amount of uh multiverses, then is that
multiverse not composed of different
component parts? And if you've got a
multiverse that's composed of different
component parts, doesn't it require an
explanation outside of itself
in order to explain its contingency?
Because everything that is made of
parts, component parts, is contingent.
And if you have a multiverse
that is made of component parts, the
multiverse would also be contingent. So
it would require something necessary
outside of itself in order to explain it
to give it explicability if you like
intelligibility.
So this is the point. You're not really
engaging and you didn't engage because
I've read your books. I've read almost
every single one of your books. You have
never you have not engaged with these
arguments.
Why is it that you've written a book of
320 pages, Richard Dawkins, or more,
which is your bestseller, and you spent
less than five pages of that book
discussing the cosmological argument,
which you know is one of the most
popular arguments for God's existence,
and you then averted and
circumnavigated the debate with William
Lane Craig, a person who I debated
myself and discussed with and he he
debated me. Why did you run away from
that? Why did you avert your attention
from that? Why did you not want to
engage with him? I think the reason is
because you know that you'll be
cornered. I believe that. I genuinely
strongly believe that. I think that you
know that when these questions are put
to you, you will not have a sufficient
answer. Prove me wrong, Richard Dawkins.
Send me an email. send me something from
we'll get your team members to send me
some kind of a you know Instagram
message or a Twitter message or
something. Let's arrange a discussion.
You've discussed with people from all
kinds of Why haven't you discussed with
Muslims yet? You spoken about Islam a
lot recently you've spoken about Islam
in your tweets and stuff. Why don't
discuss? Well, if you don't want to,
it's not a problem. We've refuted you
anyway.
Hey, you are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.